يعني و هدوء مشوب بالحذر الشديد خشيه من
رده الفعل الاسرائيليه عقب الاعلان عن
مقتل مجنده من الوحدات الخاصه التابعه
لحرس الحدود
واصابه ثلاثه جنود اخرين بجراح احدهم تصف
وصفت جراحه بالخطير ولكن غنو لنبدا في هذا
الموقع هنا كان مسرح العمليات قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حيث نتواجد الان في
حي
الجابريات وهو المطل على مخيم جنين من هذا
الشارع تحديدا دخلت معظم الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه وفق هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه وايضا مصادر اسرائيليه وكذلك
مصادر في المقاومه الفلسطينيه تم
تفجير عبوات ناسفه تحديدا هنا كما نرى
وهذا بقايا
ايه اجزاء من الجيب العسكري واضح انه حديد
صلب جدا ولكن ما حدث ان المصادر
الاسرائيليه تؤكد ان التفجير هو كان مزدوج
بمعنى تم تفجير العبوات في هذا الموقع
بدايه باحدى الاليات العسكريه او قد يكون
اكثر ومن ثم صار ال صارت احدى هذه الاليات
اتج للهروب الى موقع اخر حيث هنا في هذا
الشارع كما نرى وصولا الى هذه الحفره
الاخرى وهنا كان التفجير الثاني
لاليه العسكريه التي ادت لمقتل مجنده
واصابه الجنود الثلاثه كما نرى
عمق الحفره هنا نتيجه التفجير وا بعض
مصادر فلسطينيه تؤكد ان التفجير قد يكون
قد تم عن بعد وانه كما ذكرنا تفجير مزدوج
بحيث ان الاليه العسكريه انتقلت من موقع
الى اخر تم تفجيرها في ذلك المكان ومن ثم
الى مكان اخر بعض المنازل ال والاهالي هنا
قاموا باطلاع على بعض ما تبقى من الاليات
العسك عريه كاحدى الابواب
وايضا عدد من مخلفات الجيش كانت ملطخه
بالدماء ايضا في هذا المبنى السكني وهو
الملاصق لمنطقه التفجير كما نرى الرصاص
انتشر بكل زوايا هذا المبنى واضح انه ايضا
كان هناك على ما يبدو اشتباكات مسلحه
اضافه الى تفجير العبوات الناس ف لان
المقاومين ايضا وكنا نتابع ذلك طوال ساعات
ما بعد انتصاف الليل حتى انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال صباح هذا اليوم من مدينه جنين
حده الاشتباكات في بدايه العمليه العسكريه
والاقتحام وصولا الى لحظه تفجير العبوات
الناسفه في الاليات العسكريه بهذه العبوات
التي واضح انها يعني من النوع الكبير لم
نعد نتحدث عن عبوات ناسفه صغيره الحجم بل
بدانا نتحدث عن عبوات شديده الانفجار
تقنيه عاليه وفق عدد من مصادر مقربه من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحديدا ككتب جنين
التابعه لسرايا القدس ايضا وفق بيانات
صدرت عن كتائب شهداء الاقصى التابعه لحركه
فتح وايضا كتائب عز الدين القسام التابعه
على حركه حماس اكدوا انهم اي خاضوا
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي نحن الان نطل في هذا المشهد
على مخيم جنين حيث كانت الاليات العسكريه
على ما يبدو تحاول استهداف والدخول الى
المخيم ولكن من حي الجابريات فتعرضت لهذه
التفجيرات عبر العبوات الناسفه خلال النصف
ساعه ال قادمه غنوه ستنطلق جنازه الشهداء
السته الذين قتلتهم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مدينه تحديدا في ما تعرف
منطقه مثلث الشهداء الملاصق لبلده قباطيه
وجنوبي مدينه جنين والتي تبعد عن هذا
الموقع تقريبا من ثمانيه الى 10 كيلومترات
وكما راينا في التقرير بان الشهداء السته
وهناك شاب سابع يعاني من جراح خطيره جدا
تم قصفهم بمسيره حربيه اسرائيليه صواريخ
اطلقت على هؤلاء الشبان الذين لم يكونوا
مسلحين ولكن تم قصفهم والبعض راى وكانها
حاله انتقام بعد الاستهداف للجنود
الاسرائيليين وهذه الاليات العسكريه هنا
في حي الجابريات المطل على مخيم جنين